we didn't know but naked I'm ever just
at the last 24 hours
yeah it was a nail-biter I didn't think
of everything else was coming out so I
like I'm so happy it's like Christmas
I've got a million questions
it's a good thing um let's get started
I'm sure you'll answer none of them but
a baby was yeah interesting huh I can't
even say it because we kept it secret so
long that it's a it's still a little
gun-shy you know having it out there in
the world but I'm glad it's out that was
a big a big secret to keep but John and
I were pretty adamant that it would be
the best thing for fans if we could get
them to the finish line and they could
experience it in the episode so I think
it did its job yeah you guys made it I
mean I think that's like one of the
biggest mysteries of Star Wars is like
the background of Yoda species and
what's going on so how excited are you
for to explore it's exciting but I think
there's a lot of responsibility around
it I mean one of the reasons that I
really got interested in this story that
John was pitching was the subject of
this child and you know just knowing
George and how important the character
of Yoda is Tim I want to make sure that
I could help Shepherd this idea and that
you know we still I think we still want
to keep a lot of things a mystery we
don't want to go around answering things
and making them less special but let's
tell a story that's interesting and
compelling and you know add to this
great galaxy let me ask you this because
people were already picking apart
there's like a shot where these going
down the the bounty hunter Hall that's
okay mandalorian Enclave yeah when he's
under the ground in the story yeah okay
then bounty hunter has fine you know
what go with it that's fine it's funny
cuz like people are writing mine things
you know writing articles and they're
like baby odor cuz I don't know what
else that's fine all part of the mystery
baby you're a disclaimer but you know
but it's very clear it's very clear yeah
I'm saying but people are looking in the
background being like is that what's
interesting interesting yeah and you're
saying you think there's a possibility
he survived the Sarlacc interesting
interesting interesting I mean there's
always possibilities I don't like to
limit our storytelling in any way and
you know who knows I've been surprised
it would be really hypocritical for the
guy that helped bring Darth Maul back to
life after got cut in half for me to say
that somebody
can't survive a Sarlacc pit but I don't
know you know I mean anything's possible
in Star Wars and I always think when
fans love something that's what really
fuels the possibility and the
believability so who knows but right now
we got mando this is your first
live-action directing Star Wars gig
long-overdue is there more in the future
more episodes maybe ya know for sure I
mean it's a it's part of the you know an
experiment but experience for me was you
know George so inspired me to be
interested in live-action and I wanted
to do it you know and I wanted to see
what it was like I wanted to see what
this you know medium is as an art form
compared to animation was like I really
enjoyed it
I'm teamed up with great people and John
you know having Kathy help Shepherd me
was you know very key so it feels good
and so far so good you know I think
people like the first episode and I
think I've learned a lot since I did
that one I've got another episode I
directed later this season and you know
it's all building to something for me
which I can say I which I feel good
about I just want to tell stories then
if I feel some stories fit as
live-action then I just want to be able
to do it so we'll see I already hear
some of the same questions together okay
gods like a pro okay first episode out
of the gate a baby what we like to talk
about that yet out there the skirted
around that it's out there I said I'm
still a little gun-shy I will say this
there are characters that weren't part
of the promotional material and I have
to thank Disney and Lucasfilm because
the way the cat usually gets out of the
bag with that stuff is merchandising and
toy and toy catalogs and things like
that
so they really backed us up because we
really wanted to have it be that you had
to watch it yourself so that every time
you watch the show there are new twists
and secrets that come out but that
requires a lot of restraint
the people who are footing the bill
saying that they're gonna they're gonna
hold back on certain things so that the
public doesn't know ahead of time and
part of that was holding back on some of
the merchandising and holding back we
didn't know but make it I'm ever just at
the last 24 hours
yeah it was a nail-biter I didn't think
as everything else was coming out so I
like I'm so happy it's like Christmas
you know you don't you know I know it's
not all the Christmas presents and so we
were like parents hiding in the when the
kids are sleeping because everybody's
looking and reporting and taking
pictures but I'm glad people are so
curious about it and I'm also glad that
the light that people feel when they
discover something that they weren't
expecting so hard to do that nowadays
it's not just in Star Wars at all at all
I already want a baby Yoda plushie we
can make this happen
you know what my generation went through
because they didn't have Star Wars toys
available for the first Christmas from
get it I got a voucher for Christmas in
77
they were commercials and and and that
and I traded in the coupon it got them
redeemed so that's what that's what it
was like because you've been part of the
team for a while now I know Dave's used
to this but you've been posting pictures
from season two already on I did one
picture of a helmet from the said yeah
it's the same helmet and we were there I
was there today I posted that today I
was on the set on an alien planet today
filming and came over here I cleaned up
pretty good he was working today - did
ya under picture I was like wait wait
you have a premiere that's right here we
are thank you
thank you you've seen Cheers
[Music]